violence returns to the streets of
Nairobi with a new wave of protests
against the government
the unrest has centered in nairobi's
impoverished areas of kibera and Matari
Police use tear gas and water cannon to
push back against the clouds
[Applause]
protesters chanted slogans against the
government denouncing the rising cost of
living they demanded the resignation of
William Ruto whose election as president
they say is illegal
we want the price of cooking flour to go
down Ruto has been unable to reduce the
price of maize flour so we want Ruto to
step down
looking at the just the basic
including basic life so everyone feels
like we have had a new government that
had promised so much yet we still are
seeing that there is no improvement in
the cost of living if anything there is
constant raise and an announcement that
is everything is going to be raising you
know in a given percentage and people
feel frustrated
police said the protest was unauthorized
and illegal they warned local media
against broadcasting it more than a
dozen Civil Society groups issued a
joint statement expressing concern over
what they described as a suppression of
people's constitutional right to
Peaceful demonstration protesters say
this is just the beginning opposition
parties say they are preparing to widen
and intensify demonstrations